aprendimos en el último vídeo que si
tengo alguna matriz digamos una matriz
ce y que digamos que ésta es una matriz
de n por acá y vamos a dar digamos sus
vectores columna déjenme poner bien este
margen
más o menos si tenemos la matriz ce y
sus columnas son los vectores c1 c2 y
así sucesivamente hasta el vector seca
ok ahí tenemos nuestra matriz con estos
vectores como columnas entonces si estas
columnas formas y estos vectores
columnas forman un conjunto corto normal
ok entonces vamos a suponer que todos
estos forman un conjunto
junto a orton normal
corto
orton normal si si forman un conjunto or
tomo orton formal perdón mostramos que
si multiplicamos la matriz se
transpuesta por la matriz c esto nos iba
a dar la matriz identidad de tamaño k
verdad y ese tamaño acá porque aquí
tenemos que éste desde perdón es al
revés tenemos que éste desde acá por n
verdad que es la transporta y éste desde
n por acá entonces al final lo que nos
queda es que desde cada por acá muy bien
entonces
ahora vamos a preguntarnos qué pasa si k
es igual a n muy bien entonces la
pregunta que vamos a tratar de resolver
es bueno qué va a pasar si ahora
suponemos que k es igual a n entonces en
realidad estamos pensando que la matriz
c es una matriz es una matriz cuadrada
una matriz cuadrada verdad y sí sí
tenemos ese caso entonces
las columnas además sabemos que las
columnas por ser un conjunto [ __ ] normal
son linealmente independientes eso eso
lo vimos ya hace algunos vídeos y eso
inmediatamente también me dice sí ya lo
hemos visto que se es invertible que se
es invertible si sus matrices por ser
por ser una matriz cuadrada cuyas
columnas son linealmente independientes
entonces tenemos que nuestra matriz c es
invertible verdad de hecho de hecho
podemos decir más de hecho podemos decir
que ese 1
c2 y así todos estos
todos estos vectores son
una base del espacio con una base de
muy bien entonces esto lo que me está
diciendo es que existe alguna matriz sea
la menos 1 que si lo multiplicamos por c
por la izquierda o por la derecha de
hecho debe debe funcionar que si lo
multiplicamos por la izquierda o por la
derecha nos debe dar la matriz identidad
de tamaño n pero además por ser un
conjunto [ __ ] normal por ser un conjunto
corto normal sabemos que la matriz
transpuesta por ser verdad lo que
tenemos acá es la matriz identidad de
tamaño n aunque entonces déjenme
escribir esto tenemos que la matriz
la matriz
de n por n
por en cuyas columnas
la matriz cuyas columnas
forman un conjunto
punto
un punto corto normal si tenemos una
matriz que cumple estas características
entonces fíjense realmente como la
inversa de una matriz es única cuando
existe esto quiere decir que tanto sea
la menos 1 como se transporta son las
mismas verdad tenemos que sea la menos 1
es lo mismo que se transporta entonces
sí sí mi matriz es cuadrada es cuadrada
y sus columnas forman un conjunto harto
normal que además de todo es una base de
rn sabemos sabemos que es invertible
pero más aún sabemos que su inversa es
su matriz transpuesta y esto esto viene
de esta propiedad verdad de que en
realidad las inversas son únicas y en
ese sentido pues deben coincidir muy
bien entonces vamos a utilizar este
hecho porque puede ser muy difícil
calcular una una inversa de una matriz
para una matriz a lo mejor no sé que se
encuentren que sea de tamaño 10 x 10 o
de 100% verdad eso puede ser muy difícil
pero esto nos hace más fácil el cálculo
de esta de esta matriz entonces vamos a
utilizar un ejemplo ya pues digamos que
ya habíamos revisado para para dar una
aplicación de cómo podemos usar esto
entonces vamos a considerar los vectores
de 1
el ejemplo que ya teníamos dos tercios
menos era menos dos tercios ya
un tercio
vector también teníamos el vector v2 que
era el vector que tenía entradas dos
tercios dos tercios un tercio
y menos dos tercios
y también teníamos el vector b3 que era
el que tenía como entradas y un tercio
dos tercios
dos tercios voy
entonces este ya lo habíamos trabajado
creo que incluso varias veces en vídeos
anteriores al menos en alguno
de derecho
no importa en algunos en algún vídeo ya
habíamos visto que en realidad este es
un conjunto corto normal es un conjunto
corto normal cada uno tiene norma 1 y
además entre ellos son ortogonales
verdad entonces vamos a ver qué pasaría
vamos a ir construyendo una función a lo
mejor un poco alocada pero pero que
quede muy claro lo que queremos hacer
queremos ahora el punto de este vídeo es
construir una interesante transformación
en r3 que es lo que les había anunciado
y vamos para eso primero a tomar dos
vectores digamos el b 1 y el b 2
entonces estos dos vectores se verán
que andará
que andará el vector
que anda b1 y un vector ortogonal
digamos
que anda de 2
más o menos se ve que son ortogonales
entonces estos dos vectores generan todo
un plano verdad porque son linealmente
independientes entre ellos no son
múltiplos del otro entonces esto me
genera todo un plano en rn y por
supuesto tenemos a b3 que es ortogonal a
ellos 2 entonces a quien dará
salen tan derechitas las líneas
bueno espero se entiende el punto más o
menos ahí ya quedo b3 b3 que es
ortogonal a todo este plano y por
supuesto aquí estamos trabajando en
nuestro espacio r 3 muy bien entonces
utilizando esto tenemos que este espacio
rojo de hecho le voy a poner nombre este
de aquí es el espacio b que es el
espacio vectorial generado por los
vectores b1 y b2 que de hecho es un
plano verdad es un plano
es un plano como lo conocemos y esta
línea de tres o más bien este vector de
tres es el vector que genera una línea
que es ortogonal a todo el plan aunque
en realidad podemos generar todo el
espacio el espacio el complemento
ortogonal de b con la línea que genera
de 3 entonces la pregunta es bueno
supongamos que yo tengo por ahí un
vector digamos por aquí así
aquí este vector y yo me pregunto cuál
será el vector correspondiente que está
reflejado por debajo de este plano
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
proyectar primero al plano por ahí pega
y luego hacer esta misma distancia pero
por aquí abajo verdad entonces éste
este vector
y estará por acá va
del plan aquí es donde digamos pegaría
en el plano muy bien o si tenemos por
ejemplo un vector de este otro lado algo
así
entonces al reflejar sobre él sobre el
plano tenemos primero a donde pega y
luego hacia acá abajo
y entonces estamos pensando en la
transformación correspondiente a la
reflexión digamos de estos vectores de
cualquier vector en r3 respecto a este
plano es decir como una especie de
espejo verdad que si yo tengo un punto
aquí me fijo donde está el plano y luego
esa misma distancia proyectada se debe
ir hacia abajo y esa es la
transformación que nos interesa
encontrar ahora bien esto no es tan
sencillo de encontrar sin embargo lo que
sí podemos saber es quiénes son las
proyecciones tanto de b1 b2 y b3 por
ejemplo la transformación aplicada a b1
definitivamente pues si vamos a reflejar
respecto al plano pero ve uno está en el
plano pues entonces es el mismo verdad
la reflexión de cualquier punto del
plano
el mismo lo mismo va a pasar con la
transformación aplicada a dedos esto
será de 2
2 ahora el punto interesante de todos
estos es que pasa con la transformación
qué pasa con la transformación pero
aplicado a b3 porque al aplicar la b3 b3
definitiva en fin definitivamente ya no
está en el plano entonces lo que va a
pasar es que proyectamos sobre el plano
ok y luego tenemos que hacer esa misma
distancia
misma distancia debe 3 pero por abajo
entonces en realidad a la hora de
proyectar como es tv3 es ortogonal a
todo el plano esta proyección cae
directamente y simplemente es el inverso
de b3 es menos de 3 verdad eso es una
forma de cómo ver esta proyección
entonces vamos a hablar ahora de la
transformación lineal que habíamos
mencionado cómo expresar esta
transformación para cualquier punto del
espacio en términos de una
transformación lineal y digo quedaría
pendiente ver que es una transformación
lineal por él por el momento pueden
creerme que así es porque queremos aquí
el punto central es encontrar una
transformación en r3 que me determine
este este fenómeno ok entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es vamos a bajar primero
un poco
vamos a bajar un poco y tenemos a x y
queremos encontrar una matriz y tal que
al aplicarla tenemos nuestra
transformación verdad podemos
interpretar la transformación de x como
la multiplicación de una matriz por
equis y esto está determinado en nuestra
base estándar en nuestra base canónica
muy bien entonces como realmente no
conocemos este hecho vamos a tener que
darle la vuelta al problema por ejemplo
podemos hacer un cambio de base tomar
una base distinta y elegir
para esa base o ver cómo se vería x en
coordenadas de esa base correcto y esto
pues sabemos que es alguna matriz sea la
menos 1 ahora podemos aplicar alguna
transformación de verdad que me
determine la la transformación de x pero
en la base b y finalmente tendremos que
regresar a nuestra base original y
expresar lo en términos de nuestra base
original con la matriz c
este es el diagrama que queremos
utilizar verdad entonces
tenemos que si tx de x es igual a esta
matriz a por x le podemos dar la vuelta
al problema y utilizar varias matrices
para expresar nuestra matriz a td x
primero aplicamos como más bien sería
primero aplicamos sea la menos 1 verdad
bajamos aquí luego aplicamos de y luego
aplicamos a nuestro vector x entonces
esto inmediatamente si si nosotros nos
tomamos de una base [ __ ] normal una base
corto normal
entonces qué ocurre con ser transpuesta
por c
ok fíjense que se es la matriz de cambio
de base
entonces sí sí nuestra base es [ __ ]
normal tenemos justo el ejemplo que
tenemos anteriormente de transpuesta por
c ya sabemos que es la identidad y
además sabemos que sea la menos 1 existe
y no sólo existe que además se
transporta es la inversa de nuestra
matriz entonces utilizando esto aquí
aquí en realidad está esta está inversa
estamos hablando de la trans puesta de
nuestra matriz se verdad entonces como
estas dos son iguales y la inversa que
coincide con la trans presta estamos
pensando que a es igual a c de
transpuesta y esto es lo que vamos a
utilizar para poder resolver este
problema que habíamos planteado el de
encontrar nuestra matriz asociada a ésta
tanto a esta transformación lineal y
vamos a tomarnos una base pues muy
particular que justamente ya tenemos
aquí la base generada por b1 b2 y b3 que
por cierto es bastante útil porque de 1
y b 2 son las que son
generan a nuestro espacio ve a nuestro
plano sobre el cual queremos proyectar
ib3 pues es él es ortogonal a todo el
plan
bien entonces utilizando nuestra base ve
el conjunto que tiene a b1 b2 b3 que si
tenemos este conjunto fíjense que
realmente expresar a b1 b2 y b3 en
términos de esa base es muy sencillo por
ejemplo de uno pues simplemente va a ser
de 1 + 0 b 2
0 de 3 entonces de uno escrito déjenme
ponerlo así entonces ve uno escrito en
términos de nuestra base de no es otra
cosa más que el 100
verdad estamos reescribiendo a b1 en
términos de nuestra base nueva lo mismo
va a pasar con b 2 y con b3 quien va a
ser de 2 en términos de nuestra base b
pues simplemente será cero veces b uno
más una vez b 20 veces b 3 entonces este
es el vector 0 10 y finalmente b 3
escrito en términos de nuestra base b
nuevamente será cero veces b 10 veces b
2 pero una vez b 3 muy bien entonces ya
que está escrito de esta forma primero
nos falta ver quién es la matriz de
cambio de base que bueno es está dada
por los vectores b1 b2 y b3 y la otra
cosa que nos falta es determinar quién
no es quien es nuestra matriz d
entonces la matriz de es una matriz que
va a tener tres columnas de uno de dos y
de tres ahí están sus columnas estas son
son columnas
y tenemos que determinar quién es de uno
de dos y de tres pero vamos a hacer una
pequeña observación fíjense muy bien en
quién sería la transformación aplicada
de uno pero escrita en términos de
nuestra base ve ok entonces esto pues no
es otra cosa más que si nos tomamos el
vector de uno escrito en la base b y
aplicarle la matriz de entonces esto es
de esta forma verdad
aquí está dicho o pintado en este
diagrama ahora bien esto pues es esta
matriz que tiene columnas de uno de dos
y de tres aplicado a este vector que ya
dijimos que es el 100
y esto pues no es otra cosa si
multiplicamos todos estos solo van a
permanecer las coordenadas de de uno
entonces este es el vector de uno lo
mismo vamos a tener con la matriz perdón
la transformación aplicada a b2 pero en
términos de nuestra base ve esto es la
matriz de multiplicada por b 2 en
términos de nuestra base b y esto es la
matriz que tiene a de uno de dos de tres
que multiplica al vector ya no el 100
sino al 010 y en este caso los únicos
que las únicas coordenadas que
sobreviven son las de 2 entonces esto
simplemente es de 2
finalmente ya podrás imaginarte quién
será quién será
la transformación aplicada a b3 en
términos de nuestra base ve nuevamente
pues es la matriz que tiene a de 1
de 2 ya de 3 que multiplican al 0 0
1 y por lo tanto los únicos que
sobreviven son las coordenadas de de 3
entonces fíjense que con esta pequeña
observación ya sé quiénes son los
vectores columna de de uno de dos y de
tres son justamente cómo se verían las
imágenes o la transformación aplicada a
la base nueva a la base d
pero escritos en nuestra en esa misma
base pero más aún si sabemos quiénes son
verdad aquí los tenemos escritos aquí
están escritos entonces
de hecho déjenme déjenme bajar más para
para ir anotando todo esto la matriz de
la matriz d
por esta por esto que acabamos de
observar acá arriba es la matriz que
tiene como vectores columnas a la
transformación en b1 vista en términos
de nuestra base ve a la transformación
en b2 vista en términos de nuestra base
ve y la transformación aplicada de tres
vista en términos de nuestra base ve
estas son las columnas del de la matriz
de y además sabemos que te debe 1
como lo habíamos visto ya anteriormente
te aplicado a b1 b1 te aplicado en b2 es
de dos
aplicado a b3 es menos de 3 entonces
realmente podremos reescribir estos
vectores en términos de nuestra base
original perdón en términos de nuestra
base b que es la nueva ok de hecho pues
sabemos ya que ya que está descrito de
esta forma que te aplicado a b1 la
transformación en términos de b pues es
simplemente b1 en términos de b y eso
sabemos muy bien que no es de hecho está
aquí arriba es el 100
también sabemos quién sería y de hecho
podemos ir escribiendo quién es nuestra
matriz de la primera columna es 100 muy
bien quién sería de la transformación
aplicada al vector de 2
en términos de nuestra base ve pues eso
es v2 en términos de la base ve
términos de la base ve y esto es como ya
lo habíamos visto anteriormente 0 1 0
entonces en esta segunda columna es 0 1
ahora quien nos falta ver pues la
transformación aplicada a b3
entonces la transformación aplicada a b3
respecto a la base ve es menos b3
- b3 escrito en la base ve pero menos b3
simplemente es 0 veces ve 10 veces ve 2
y menos una vez b 3 entonces este es
casi el que teníamos excepto que aquí va
un -1 y por lo tanto esta matriz es casi
la identidad
excepto que lleva un -1 en esta esquina
ok y con esto ya podemos hallar muy bien
quién es la matriz a verdad porque la
matriz a estaba dada de esta forma
de esta forma ya sabemos quiénes es la
sede es la matriz que tiene como
columnas a estos vectores y de ya
sabemos bueno la acabamos de encontrar
que es casi la identidad de excepto por
un signo y se transporta es fácilmente
calculable entonces vamos a copiar esto
que tenemos aquí
esto que tenemos aquí vamos a copiarlo
a copiarlo y pegarlo para tenerlo más
presente más cerca de nosotros
pegarlo
por aquí muy bien
muy bien entonces el hecho esto esto
solo necesitamos esto es para era parte
del dibujo
con esto y ya que tenemos esto entonces
ya podemos ir escribiendo quién es
nuestra matriz a nuestra matriz a como
dijimos era
sé que en este caso es la matriz que
tiene a estos vectores como columna y de
hecho podemos factorizar de un tercio
verdad vamos a escribirlo como un tercio
que multiplica a 2 menos 21
aquí vamos a tener un tercio que
multiplicados 1 - 2 2 1
- 2
12 21 22
esta es la matriz ce quien es la matriz
de la matriz de la acabamos de encontrar
es casi la identidad
así la identidad excepto por este último
menos 1
y se inversa que eso que esencialmente
se transpuesta es un tercio verdad por
qué pasó así trans ponemos la matriz ce
es decir la matriz que tiene a estos
como como vectores
como columnas más bien entonces es en
realidad esta matriz transpuesta este
este renglón perdón esta columna pasa a
ser renglón y es 2 - 2 1 este esta
columna pasa a ser renglón 2
1 - 2 y esta columna pasa a ser
nuevamente renglón entonces ya tenemos
la forma de encontrar a ahora
simplemente vamos a tener que calcular
esta multiplicación de hecho esto de
aquí es que estoy aquí es se transpuesta
y esta de aquí en medio está de aquí en
medio
la matriz de muy bien entonces vamos a
quitar esto que tenemos aquí
quitarlo ya no lo vamos a ocupar
para tener espacio y calcular todo esto
entonces si ahora nos tomamos digamos
vamos a multiplicar estas dos matrices
primero de hecho podemos multiplicar el
un tercio y el un tercio primero
vemos que es un noveno este tercio y
este tercio y qué pasa si multiplicamos
estas dos bueno si tenemos este renglón
vamos a empezar con este renglón
multiplicado por esta columna tenemos
dos por uno es 2 2 por 0 0 1 por 0 0
entonces tenemos en esta primera entrada
2 si ahora multiplicamos por este
renglón lo que nos queda es 0 2 y 1 lo
que lo que resulta es 2 y ahora
finalmente con esta con esta columna
tenemos 2 por 0 0 2 por 0 0 y 1 por
menos 1 es menos 1 entonces quizás ya te
empezaste a dar cuenta que es lo que va
a estar pasando cuando multipliquemos
aquí verdad porque en realidad si si
ahora nos tomamos el siguiente renglón
este renglón menor si multiplicamos este
por esta columna el único que sobrevive
es el menos 2 verdad lo demás tiene
ceros luego si lo multiplicamos por esta
columna nos sobrevive sólo el 1 verdad y
si lo multiplicamos por esta columna
sólo sobrevive el 2 pero con signo
contrario entonces aquí va a un -2 de
hecho si te das cuenta son los mismos
renglones pero escritos con su última
coordenada con menos verdad entonces si
nos tomamos ahora por ejemplo este lo
que nos va a quedar es el mismo verdad
es 1 menos 2 y con el último signo
cambiado ahí tenemos esta primera
multiplicación y ahora falta multiplicar
por ser transpuesta por ser transpuesta
2 y 1
muy bien esta va a ser la parte más
complicada del problema vamos a quitar
esto que ya no ya no lo necesitamos y
vamos a tratar de resolverlo de forma
muy ágil muy bien entonces como ya
sabemos multiplicar matrices va a ser
igual a un noveno y a multiplicar el
primer renglón vamos a tomarnos este
primer renglón por este que es 2 x 2 es
42 por dos es 4 a ivan 8 y menos uno por
uno es menos uno tenemos siete ahora
este por este 2 por 2 2 por menos 12
menos 4 2 por 1 es 2 y eso me da menos 2
y menos uno por 2 es menos 2 con menos 2
nos queda menos 4
y ahora con esta columna dos por uno es
22 por menos 12 es menos 4 y eso hasta
ahí vamos menos dos y menos uno por dos
es menos dos con menos dos es menos
cuatro muy bien ahí tenemos nuestra
primera
nuestro primer renglón vámonos con el
siguiente tenemos ahora este que vamos a
multiplicar por cada columna menos dos
por dos es menos 4 1 por 2 3 2 con menos
4 es menos 2 y menos dos por uno es
menos dos así que aquí nos queda menos
cuatro menos dos por menos dos es cuatro
uno por uno es uno y eso nos da 5 me
parece que 5
lo que es menos 2 x menos dos es cuatro
uno por uno es 1
y eso nos da
exacto sí y menos dos por dos es menos
cuatro que con cinco nos queda
simplemente uno ya me estaba
confundiendo ahora menos dos por uno es
menos dos uno por menos dos es menos dos
y que con otro menos dos es cuatro y
ahora menos dos por dos
es
otra vez se me estoy confundiendo a ver
tenemos menos 2 x 1 es menos 21 x menos
2 es menos 2 a iván menos 4 y menos 2 x
2 es menos 4 con menos 4 nos da menos 8
muy bien casi y ahora ya vamos con el
último vamos con este renglón y es uno
por 2-2 menos dos por dos es menos
cuatro con dos es menos dos y menos dos
por uno es menos cuatro verdad bueno
menos dos por uno es menos dos con el
menos dos que llevaba es menos -4 vamos
con el siguiente uno por menos dos es
menos dos menos dos por uno es menos dos
a iván menos 4 y menos dos por dos
es menos cuatro con los menos cuatro que
llevaba es menos ocho y luego el último
uno por uno es uno menos dos por menos
dos es cuatro con uno llevan cinco y
menos dos por dos es menos cuatro con
cinco me queda uno entonces esta es la
matriz asociada a nuestra transformación
es decir t
es igual a x donde a es esta matriz pero
esto hubiera sido realmente difícil de
calcular por nuestra cuenta darnos
cuenta que a lo mejor aquí va el 7 al
menos 4 y demás ni siquiera sabíamos
bien cómo encontrar la transformación de
los vectores de la base canónica que es
lo que usualmente hacemos para encontrar
esta matriz de transformación en cambio
hicimos un cambio de base a partir de
este de este diagrama está bastante
agradable que de hecho aquí lo había
copiado con este este diagrama pudimos
hacer un cambio de base a otra base
orton normal y el hecho de que fuera
corto normal hizo muy sencillo encontrar
la inversa en nuestra matriz de cambio
de base de todos modos espero que hayas
encontrado esto muy útil